attends oh j'ai de
flire toi ouais mais ça va ça va j'ai
mais il y en
a c'est c'est ça les
chutes
s
l'eau joli ce
vert
oigé fa
p comme
laisine
la surface est très belle ta
gauche tu un peu à
gauchearrive
c'est plus beau à la surface audessus de
l'eau tu ah oui je vois le plire
làis à gauche partout ah c'est vachement
beau
là
bon pas beaucoup
de pas beaucoup de vie làdedans
attention tu penstion
des mecs qui pêcheraient ça serait super
là personne de personne
là
arcenciel attend on va s'arrêter sur un
truc
voilà attend je l'arcenciel
j'arrive
j'ai attends
ouais
ok tu
coupess allez un mec en bas avec une
barque mais il c'est rien du
tout c'est pas un mec d'ailleurs c'est
une barque toute
seule beau quand ça passer en contre
jour peut-être un petit peu mais
bon
en a plein laisse
tomber quand on va revenir ça ira mieux
commence à prendre bien du
FL attends attends c'est
pas je sais pas une s de Ch tu
vouiso je pas je voulais faire une
s où il fa que
j'aille je sais pas je
jeour un pe
peu
pas
vara do go
mai
les dernièr on s'appuie
d'accord la dernière encore pas
celle celle qui peu bar ok
ok dans milieu làil à
droite
le trou de
l'enferen
intégr ok je dans
l'au
joli
de personne de personne
par doucement la rivière su doucement
enant c'est joli avec le en fond le le
fond